[Music]
so guys I don't know the last time you
jumped on a trampoline have you jumped
on a trampoline recently fantastic you
got to do it I hadn't jumped on a
trampoline as an adult and apparently I
love jumping on trampolines and I got to
jump on a trampoline because the US
Olympic Trials start tomorrow
and I went to a facility where they were
all practicing with an Olympic hopeful
freestyle skier Devin Logan and we
tramped it up big-time check it out
this is really fun for me this is Devin
Logan one of my favorite people and she
is a free skier and an Olympic hopeful
what's free skiing free skiing two
events halfpipe and slopestyle halfpipe
just like Shaun White you ditch
slopestyle it's just like the skate park
only on skis you just got a real happy
vibe like it's Saturday morning and
we're gonna eat Cap'n Crunch and watch
tunes why are we gonna jump on tramps
trampolines if what you do is here well
the trampoline is a good way just to
practice your tricks before you actually
take them on snow so you don't eat it
and hurt yourself so you know what
you're doing you don't want to eat it no
unless it's carbs before the man yep
nice awesome
sweet
it's spectacular toe-touch spread-out
toe touch sit down I'm back no laugh at
laugh at slink right huh okay just kind
of sloppy okay like a baby giraffe just
jump yeah I just started jumping with
your basic bounce I'm just getting used
to the trampoline I'll start with a
basic bounce basic box okay oh Jesus
yeah yeah seat you're out no problem
no good no mistakes
first take keep rolling son of a [ __ ]
I'm so good help with the seat I keep a
hard core when you seat drop and then
come up back to feet you had me at hard
core so much joy on a trampoline and you
can buy one with American money if we
were both on the [ __ ] could we
high-five and free freeze-frame oh yeah
inside of these cubes it's like a pile
of tesseracts oh whoa nice we're here on
planet tempur-pedic in the memory foam
galaxy to finish the most amazing
interview I'm gonna say of both of our
lives was I the most impressive amateur
you've ever seen you progress really
fast more than I thought you would got
that
you swear in your interviews hi I try
not to
would you like to all right let's do the
best times balls penis diarrhea [ __ ] but
liquor but liquor and estimated you
young Jedi you want to win a medal - I
want to win - two medals isn't it more
important that we feel like champions in
our hearts yeah but I'd feel better to
have some bling around your neck - yeah
something to rub in your highschool
nemesis's face this was the most fun
I've ever had in my life
and you're the coolest can't wait to see
what a spectacular young lady you're
gonna you're gonna just I just feel like
you're gonna make us all so proud thanks
dad
I'm intim suck it suck it every day send
me a postcard from Sukkot Devin it's
hard enough Devin I will turn this car
around we'll turn this damn bus around
there and your precious little field
trip that was real
[Applause]
[Music]